[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
der erste wahlsonntag dieses jahres
guten abend und willkommen an meiner
seite ist katja stresow für den sport
genannt und das sind die wichtigsten
nachrichten themen dieses sonntags
das saarland wird ruft mit großem
abstand gewinnt die spd bei der
landtagswahl und kann die cdu nach über
20 jahren als stärkste kraft ablösen
angriffe auf treibstofflager russland
bombardiert in der ukraine öl depots
damit die verteidiger vom nachschub
abgeschnitten werden
und die tafeln schlagen alarm kostenlose
lebensmittel für bedürftige werden knapp
weil es immer mehr andrang gibt und
gleichzeitig immer weniger zu verteilen
ein paukenschlag kommt da aus dem
saarland die spd mit ihrer frontfrau
anke rehlinger jubelt über einen
haushohen wahlsieg nach zehn jahren
großer koalition kann sie vielleicht
sogar mit absoluter mehrheit allein
regieren
weit abgeschlagen ist die cdu mit
noch-ministerpräsident tobias hans die
grünen sind wohl knapp drin im landtag
alle anderen parteien sind raus oder
müssen noch bangen matthias frauen auf
im wahlstudio in saarbrücken hat die
aktuellen zahlen und die sind deutlich
matthias so sieht's aus guten abend hier
kommt die nächste hochrechnung punkt 19
uhr in der reihenfolge der parteien wie
sie auf den stimmzetteln hier stand die
cdu
28,0 die spd 43,2 prozent deutlich
stärkste partei die linke sicher nicht
mehr im parlament vertreten 2,5 die afg
5,4 prozent wäre drin die grünen 5,5
prozent ebenso und bei der fdp es ist
ganz ganz knapp mit 4,9 prozent sehen
wir sie im moment knapp unter der fünf
prozent hürde
wir schauen mal nach gewinnen und
verlusten was sich bei so viel bewegung
im parteien verhältnis absolut lohnt die
cdu verliert mehr als zwölf punkte die
spd gewinnt mehr als 13 punkte die linke
verliert 10 punkte die afg verliert ein
kleines bisschen die grünen gewinnen
etwas deutlicher hinzu ebenso die fdp ob
es reicht wie gesagt ist trotzdem nicht
klar und auch bei den anderen gibt es zu
gewinnen zwölf kleine parteien
eine von denen hat mehr als zwei prozent
die sitzverteilung im saarbrücker
landtag die absolute mehrheit liegt bei
26 sitzen cdu käme auf 18 die spd auf 27
die afd auf drei und die grünen
ebenfalls auf drei und jetzt schauen wir
darauf was das heißen kann fürs regieren
hier im saarland und da haben wir zwei
szenarien die fdp unter fünf prozent da
hatten wir sie gerade noch haarscharf
wenn das so käme hätte die spd eine
absolute mehrheit mit 27 sitzen ist also
über die senkrechten linie von 26 sitzen
die man mindestens braucht werden die
fdp aber noch reinkommt und über 5%
kriegt dann wird's knapp dann hätte die
spd immer noch eine absolute mehrheit
aber haarscharf mit 26 sitzen und das
könnte sich im laufe des abends noch
verschieden aber sie könnte natürlich
eine große koalition bilden und anführen
sie könnte auch ein rot grünes bündnis
anführen oder sozial liberal machen wenn
die fdp drin ist all diese bündnisse
relativ deutlich mehr als 26 sitze ein
wort noch zur wahlbeteiligung die ist
gesunken von knapp 70 prozent auf jetzt
63 prozent dankeschön matthias für den
moment in der regel bekommt er oder die
regierende einen amtsbonus im fall von
tobias hans hat das nicht geklappt er
und die große gewinnerin des abends sind
jetzt bei bettina schausten in der runde
und wir dürfen gespannt sein wie sie
dieses wahlergebnis erklären bettina
baba und wir beginnen bei dem bisherigen
ministerpräsidenten tobias hans das ist
ein bitterer abend hat er uns gerade
schon gesagt ein desaströses ergebnis
für die cdu was ist schiefgelaufen herr
hans und was für konsequenzen ziehen sie
auch persönlich jetzt also zunächst mal
ist das in der tat eine er aber
niederlage alle umfragen haben sich nun
bestätigt wir haben nach über 22 einhalb
jahren
eine niederlage erlitten die wir so
nicht erwartet hätten und das schmerzt
natürlich sehr ist eine bittere
niederlage natürlich auch für meine
person die er unmittelbar mit diesem
wahlkampf auch verbunden waren deswegen
trage ich natürlich auch die
verantwortung und werde ich auch
persönliche konsequenzen ziehen aus
diesem wahlergebnis das ist für mich
selbstverständlich in schwierigen zeiten
veranstalter die zu übernehmen wir
werden das morgen in den gremien der
partei die cdu saar ist eine sehr
geschlossene partei besprechen
miteinander und dann auch entsprechend
darüber informieren was wenn sie vor
allem was schief gelaufen das sind
natürlich sehr viele dinge wenn man so
viele prozentpunkte einbüßte ist es
nicht nur das eine thema aber fakt ist
dass es uns in diesem wahlkampf nicht
gelungen ist die themen in den
vordergrund zu stellen und auch mir
persönlich als spitzenkandidat ist es
nicht gelungen die menschen zu
überzeugen mit den zukunftsthemen die
mir wichtig waren das ist alles hinter
das krisen-management zurückgetragen
willkommen in der korona pandemie und
das mag sicherlich einer der
wesentlichen gründe seien aber auf der
anderen seite haben wir gerade eben ja
auch gesehen dass das parteienspektrum
sich im saarland völlig verändert hat
der linkspartei die von zweistellig auf
unter ferner liefen gefallen ist
persönlichkeiten haben sich dort
zurückgezogen die wichtig waren für die
partei die grünen mit einer sehr
schwierigen situation und diese
wählerinnen und wähler sind
offensichtlich dann er ins lager der spd
gewechselt werden wir unsere wähler
nicht entsprechend mobilisieren konnten
viel stoff für die analyse ja frau
rehlinger die ergebnisse sind klar und
wenn man sich die zeichnungen ansieht
dann haben sie freie wahl im prinzip
wissen sie schon was sie machen jetzt da
wir sehen hier vor allem dass wir noch
ganz gut beraten sind den abend
abzuwarten denn es ist ja noch nicht
ganz entschieden wer letztendlich in den
saarländischen landtag mit einziehen
wird aber ganz unabhängig davon bleibt
es bei dem was ich vorher gesagt habe
stabilität ist für mich das
entscheidende kriterium bei dieser
regierungsbildung dabei spielt immer
mathematik auch eine rolle aber nicht
nur sondern es geht auch darum dass man
vertrauen zueinander hat das auch den
handelnden personen etwas zugetraut wird
und da entlang werde auch die
entscheidungen in zukunft getroffen
werden wir freuen uns natürlich über
dieses starke mandat das wir erhalten
haben und werden natürlich für das land
das beste daraus machen ich will ganz
persönlich noch mal ein herzliches wort
des dankes auch sagen zumindest für die
zusammenarbeit bisher wie es weitergehen
wird das werden wir sicherlich sehen ich
glaube es war eine gute arbeit für
dieses land und ich sage zu wenn der
landtag zur ministerpräsidentin welt das
auch eine gute arbeit den folgen wird
wir schauen zu den grünen lisa becker
ist die spitzenkandidatin der
wiedereinzug in den landtag ist
geschaffter sieht man ein fröhliches
gesicht gleichwohl warum konnte doch
nicht mehr schwung abgegriffen werden
aus berlin wo er die grünen jetzt in der
regierung sind jetzt zunächst mal warten
wir das ergebnis ab ob es dann auch
dabei bleibt sollte das so bleiben
freuen wir uns natürlich sehr über
diesen erfolg man kann die situation
hier im saarland nicht mit der der
bundes partei vergleichen wir hatten
eine schwierige ausgangslage und von
daher sind wir froh über dieses ergebnis
so ist dann auch dabei bleiben sollte
er wird die afg sie sind drin nach
jetzigen stand sie haben verloren lag
das ein bisschen daran dass sie sich
auch auf keinen kandidaten einigen
konnten dass ihre parteien etwas
chaotisches bild abgegeben hat in
letzter zeit ja das ist oder anzuweisen
das ist zum einen kein guter tag für
kleine parteien heute gewesen keine
frage ich denke das liegt auch an der
ukraine krise da holten die leute her zu
den großen parteien sicherheitsgefühl
wir haben leider unsere themen nicht
halten können nicht spielen können das
kommt von der bundestagswahl mit zehn
prozent waren im januar etwa bei 9
prozent bedauerlich aber ich sehe es mit
einem lachenden und einem weinenden auge
wichtig war wir sind drin in der
gleichen anzahl an mandatsträgern und
daher kann ich gut leben
petra ihnen wird noch gezittert denke
ich mal sie haben dazu gewonnen aber es
ist nicht ganz so wie sie sich das
erhofft hatten richtig na ja zunächst
mal gesagt wir warten das ergebnis noch
ab wir sind eigentlich sehr
zuversichtlich dass es noch klappt
andere hochrechnungen sehen uns
mittlerweile schon bei 5,1 insofern
könnte das jetzt zuversichtlich der
wahlkampf war insofern natürlich sehr
schwierig weil die frage wer wird
ministerpräsident oder
ministerpräsidentin dieses landes die
entscheidende frage war wie die den
ganzen wahlkampf auch überschattet hat
da hatten es alle kleinen parteien sehr
sehr schwer das sieht man ja auch daran
dass die beiden parteien die als
opposition jetzt schon im landtag waren
ebenfalls sehr große schwierigkeiten
hatten auch die wähler zu mobilisieren
und umso schwieriger ist es natürlich
für uns als außerparlamentarische
opposition die wir jetzt zehn jahre
waren da die entsprechende wahrnehmungen
einfach zu bekommen und das erklärt
wahrscheinlich das knappe ergebnis aber
wir sind sehr zuversichtlich dass es
noch klappt zum ende des abends gut es
ist alles noch nicht ganz klar soweit
unsere runde hier aus dem saarland eines
ist klar nämlich der machtwechsel und es
wird hier eine neue ministerpräsidentin
geben anke rehlinger zurück nach mainz
dankeschön bettina schausten und susanne
freitag
das saarland ist flächenmäßig das
kleinste bundesland mit 750.000
wahlberechtigten und doch wird das
ergebnis auch in der hauptstadt genau
beobachtet denn diese wahl ist der erste
stimmungstest für die ampelkoalition und
sie ist die erste wahl in der amtszeit
des neuen cdu-chefs friedrich merz hier
erste reaktionen aus berlin
es ist ein wahnsinnig toller erfolg den
anke rehlinger den die spd dort im
saarland eingefahren haben nach 23
jahren schafft man es die cdu-führung
abzulösen das ist vor allem der erfolg
von anke rehlinger die eine unfassbar
starke ministerin
vize-ministerpräsidentin war und gefühlt
war sie eigentlich schon die
ministerpräsidentin und jetzt wird sie
es offiziell als noch recht frisch
gewählter generalsekretär muss ich sagen
dass das natürlich für uns für uns
überzeugte christdemokraten ein bitterer
abend ein schmerzhaftes ergebnis sind
damit nicht zufrieden und als wir die
cdu sind wir im saarland nicht in der
situation irgendwelche forderungen zu
stellen das zeichnet sich ab dass es
wieder eine starke stimme gibt für
klimaschutz im landtag im saarland das
ist sehr erfreulich und großer
rückenwind für uns unsere arbeit auch im
bund wir hatten uns sicherlich ein zwei
prozent mehr gewünscht das wird mir
jetzt auswerten wir wären mal den
wahlabend abwarten aber insgesamt bin
ich erstmal zufrieden dass wir wieder
als korrektiv in saarländischen landtag
vertreten sind das saarland ist kein
einfaches pflaster für uns dass es jetzt
gelingen könnte dass wir die chance
haben stand jetzt in den landtag des
saarlandes einzuziehen dass wir auch
guten
rückenwind hatten während des wahlkampfs
das ist ein
beachtlicher erfolg das ergebnis ist mit
sicherheit davon geprägt dass die linke
im saarland durchaus über die letzten
jahre heftige auseinandersetzung geführt
hat und es ist wie es ist man wird keine
zerstrittenen parteien das ergebnis
bekommen wir heute anderen deutlichkeit
dass es für uns wirklich bitter und ein
desaster
wollen wir uns dazu die einschätzung von
theo koll aus berlin eine heftige
klatsche vor allem für die cdu im
saarland war das wie sehr trifft das die
bundes-cdu und im neuen parteichef und
eine hohe symbolische bedeutung immerhin
hat die partei 23 jahre lang
ununterbrochen den ministerpräsidenten
gestellt und schlechter hat sie nur 1955
abgeschnitten also 2017 hatte man im
saarland sogar den schuld zug der spd
gestoppt und ein erfolgreiches wahljahr
eingeläutet diesmal aber hat die
bundes-cdu sehr frühzeitig eine
brandschutzmauer zu tobias hans
eingezogen seine performance wurde als
nicht überzeugend bewertet angeblich hat
man schon früh die wahl verloren gegeben
intern und das absehbar schwache
wahlergebnis sollte dann nicht zu fest
an der merz schon jacke kleben bleiben
der neue cdu vorsitzende war zwar zu
einer klausur im saarland hat sich aber
bei wahlkampfauftritten mit hans seinen
eher schlanken fuß gemacht für die
bundes-cdu dürften die kommenden wahlen
in schleswig holstein und nordrhein
westfalen wichtiger seien jetzt
allerdings unter sehr gedämpften
vorzeichen dankeschön nach berlin flog
direkt hier im anschluss schalten wir
wieder ins zdf wahlstudio sie können
sich aber auch mit unserer heute app auf
dem laufenden halten dort ebenfalls
immer die neuesten zahlen entwicklungen
und reaktionen der gewinner und
verlierer
jetzt zum krieg in der ukraine
da soll es nach angaben aus kiew wieder
direkte gespräche zwischen den
konfliktparteien geben und zwar ab
morgen in der türkei russland setzt
seine massiven angriffe unterdessen fort
auch labour ganz im westen ist betroffen
thomas garcia und michael mertes
berichten
gigantische tanks in flammen fast ein
sinnbild für den schier nicht enden
wollenden krieg wenn es erst mal brennt
ist löschen kaum möglich 14 stunden
dauert der kampf gegen das feuer die
angst ist endgültig angekommen in
lemberg 80 kilometer vor polen
die erste rakete schlug dort ein dann
ein zweiter anschlag der dritte warf
mich zu boden
vor dem krieg hatten wir hier ein leben
nun nicht mehr wir existieren nur noch
es waren wieder russische luftangriffe
bestätigt moskau und zeigt diese bilder
im visier angeblich militärdepots ziel
sei die versorgung abzuschneiden demnach
wurde in lemberg auch eine militärische
reparaturwerkstatt angegriffen in duplo
weitere treibstofftanks und in kharkiv
ein forschungsreaktor
der war aber inaktiv keine gefahr
beteuern ukrainische behörden
austrag erreichen uns diese bilder die
zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine in ruinen
zerstörte wohnhäuser erzeugen von
wochenlangen russischen vor stößen und
kämpfen beobachter melden moskau nun
einige truppen richtung dann was ab doch
es bleiben leid und hilflosigkeit
das gas ist abgedreht wäre welches da
könnte man wings ist suppe kochen aber
weg gehen fügte die frau hinzu wohin
soll ich denn um angriffe abzuwehren
bittet der präsident den westen um
panzer und flugzeuge
die ukraine kann russische raketen nicht
mit flinten oder maschinengewehren
abschießen von denen haben wir genug
wie sich schützen in der form als
anderthalb millionen stadtrat geht das
jetzt am ehesten in der u-bahn 100
zivilisten viele frauen und kinder in
einer stadt unter der stadt
in einem land das mal ein ganz normales
leben kannte
[Musik]
die rede des us-präsidenten von gestern
halt nach russland zeigt sich empört
über beides aussage putin dürfe nicht an
der macht bleiben aus dem kreml hieß es
über die führung in russland entscheiden
nicht beiden der präsident werde vom
russischen volk gewählt biden hatte
putin gestern bei seiner rede in
warschau als diktator und tyrann
bezeichnet er endete mit den worten um
gottes willen dieser mann kann nicht an
der macht bleiben
frank lortz in washington war dieser
satz des us präsidenten ein versehen
er stand jedenfalls nicht im manuskript
und überlagert aber nun natürlich was
beiden in dieser rede eigentlich sagen
wollte er beschrieb einen epochalen
kampf zwischen demokratie und autokratie
ein kampf um die freiheit der die
aufgabe dieser generation sei und am
ende dieser sehr intensiven und
eindringlichen rede hat er sich dann
dazu hinreißen lassen zu sagen putin
könne nicht an der macht bleiben er hat
damit wir das gelegentlich tut und wofür
er hier geradezu berüchtigt ist etwas
ausgesprochen was wohl viele denken aber
was diplomatisch natürlich unglücklich
ist denn putin kann nun behaupten dass
daraus hervorging was die usa also
tatsächlich wollten nämlich seinen sturz
und einen regimewechsel
und deswegen hat sich das weiße haus
sehr beeilt das wieder einzufangen und
auch außenminister blinken hat heute
noch einmal betont dass es darum dass es
beiden darum gegangen sei dass er nicht
die macht über die nachbarländer haben
könne und das regime wechsel auch
weiterhin nicht das ziel der us politik
sei also ein leichtes zurückrudern in
washington danke schön claudia bates
der us präsident sagte in seiner rede
gestern auch dass sich die welt auf
einen langen konflikt einstellen müsse
um die künftige internationale ordnung
ähnlich äußerte sich heute
bundespräsident steinmeier auf einem
solidaritäts hat der berliner
philharmoniker im schloss bellevue dort
spielten unter anderem musiker aus
belarus russland und der ukraine
in einer videobotschaft schwor
steinmeier die deutschen auf härtere
zeiten ein
trotz aller laufenden diplomatischen
bemühungen um eine beendigung des
krieges unsere solidarität und unsere
unterstützung
unsere standhaftigkeit auch unsere
bereitschaft zu einschränkungen
werden noch auf lange zeit gefordert
sein
und was wenn auch deutschland bedroht
werden würde kann sich das land dann
ausreichend verteidigen die regierung
will die bundeswehr mit 100 milliarden
euro stärken und denkt dabei auch über
einen deutschlandweiten
raketenschutzschirm nach ein system nach
israelischem vorbild als ersatz für das
schon ältere patrick andreas huppert
berichtet
dass flugabwehrraketen system patch wird
ist so etwas wie der nato standard für
die sicherung gegen feindliche angriffe
aus der luft flugzeuge raketen oder
marschflugkörper können bekämpft werden
auch die bundeswehr vertraut auf dieses
system aus amerikanischer produktion
noch patriot ist in die jahre gekommen
einige verteidigungsexperten fordern
deshalb eine neue leistungsfähigere
luftabwehrwaffen die aktuelle
bedrohungslage zeigt ganz klar wir
brauchen ein solches system deutschland
und europa ist aktuell ging eine solche
bedrohung nicht ausreichend gewappnet
iron dome eisenkuppel so nennen die
israelis ihr luftabwehr schutzschild
bestückt mit modernen raketen
hundertfach erprobt in den letzten
jahren gegen die angriffe der hamas
terroristen iron dome könnte auch eine
mögliche variante für deutschland sein
israelisch stellen so etwas sehr und
deswegen machte sehen eben auf diese
verschiedenen unterschiedlichen
szenarien sich mit nicht nur mit zu
beschäftigen sondern gegebenenfalls auch
umgehen zu kaufen aber das muss eben
alles sehr schnell gehen aber eben auch
sehr seriös gesprochen werden die grünen
zweifeln ob israels iron dome die
passende lösung
das ist nicht auf nato oder deutschland
eins zu eins zu übertragen da geht es um
kurzstreckenraketen da geht es um ein
sehr kleines territorium und da geht es
auch darum dass man vorher weiß von
welchen stellen diese raketen
abgeschossen werden die
einsatzbereitschaft der patriots ist
momentan wichtiger denn je im zuge des
russischen angriffs auf die ukraine hat
deutschland vor einer woche mehrere
systeme im nato auftrag in die slowakei
verlegt
corona inflation und jetzt noch der
ukraine krieg immer mehr menschen sind
hierzulande auf die hilfe der tafeln
angewiesen dort jedoch werden die regale
immer leerer beispiel ravensburg dort
gibt es seit einigen wochen etwa 35
prozent weniger lebensmittelspenden
ähnlich ist es in berlin etwa 33 prozent
weniger in frankfurt gingen die spenden
sogar um rund 80 prozent zurück und auch
in sachsen anhalt gibt es probleme wie
sammel fahrt für die tafeln im harz
simone rache und ihre kollegen fahren
die supermärkte ab um spenden abzuholen
die ausbeute aber ist gering was man
sonst jetzt mal jetzt hier treibt dann
wollt dass uns sechs kisten
wenn man jetzt obst gemüse brot und das
waren ja palettenweise manchmal das hat
sie schon krass bemerkbar gemacht die
supermärkte kaufen sparsamer waren ein
da bleibt für die tafeln weniger übrig
und auch die privaten spenden gingen in
den vergangenen monaten zurück laut
landesverband in sachsen anhalt um 20
prozent viele spenden jetzt für die
ukraine weil eben halt sehr viel weniger
abgegeben wird oder eben halt auch in
hilfstransporte geht was auch richtig
ist und die tafel unterstützt selber
auch die ukraine und die anrainerstaaten
aber wir weisen sehr stark darüber finde
es natürlich die menschen die in
deutschland sind und hilfe brauchen auch
weiter diese hilfe bekommen sollen denn
die zahl der kundinnen steigt hier in
bernburg haben sich in den vergangenen
monaten mehr als 300 bedürftige neu
registriert wegen steigender preise sind
sie auf die günstigen lebensmittel
angewiesen und auch viele ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer brauchen starthilfe
das leben in europa ist teuer und ich
habe hier noch keine arbeit deswegen
denke ich dass ich die hilfe der tafeln
weiter in anspruch nehmen werde
die ehrenamtlerinnen der tafeln hoffen
dass ihr angebot aufrechterhalten können
dafür zählt jede spende jetzt
kommen sie zum fußball nach sinsheim zur
nationalen wirtschaft genau sehr viel
zufriedenheit gestern abend denn es war
ein erfolgreiches testspiel der
deutschen fußball-nationalmannschaft
gegen israel ziel war es so viel wie
möglich auszuprobieren auf dem weg zur
wm in katar tore wurden auch geschossen
zwei von deutschland heute wurden vor
dem teamhotel extra tische aufgebaut so
groß der andrang an diesem sonnentag
hansi flick lässt sich von den jüngsten
erfolgen nicht blenden nenner solide 2 0
durch die tore der chelsea-profi sky
herz und timo werner war kein wirklicher
wm stress test ein müheloser sieg der
aber hätte deutlich höher ausfallen
müssen ein großer und ganz wenig
zufrieden wir haben ja wie ich auch gute
chancen herausgespielt aber wenn man so
will ist so ein bisschen die effizienz
die hat gefehlt und auch da aber denke
ich mal auch luft nach oben die
geschonten oder eingewechselten spieler
wie sami werden gegen die niederlande
wieder in der startelf stehen genauso
wie manuel neuer der heute seinen 36
geburtstag feiert
formel-1-pilot mit schumacher fährt
heute nicht um punkte beim großen preis
von saudi arabien in jeddah schumacher
war gestern im qualifying mit mehr als
250 km h in die streckenbegrenzung
gekracht großer schreckmoment im
gesamten harz team der 23 re blieb
unverletzt sein wagen hingegen ist
schrott in zwei wochen sollen fahrer und
auto dann in australien wieder zur
verfügung stehen und noch zum skifliegen
in planica slowenien karl geiger hart
wie fast schon erwartet die große
kristallkugel für den gesamt weltcupsieg
verpasst immerhin wurde er gesamtzweiter
hinter dem japaner ryo kobayashi für
einen anderen war der letzte sprung der
saison auch der letzte sein langen
erfolgreichen karriere
severin freund weltmeister und
olympiasieger verlässt auf den schultern
deutscher teamkollegen die
internationale skisprung welt einer
seiner potenziellen nachfolger der
oberstdorfer karl geiger sprang beim
weltcup finale in planica mit einem sehr
guten zweiten versuch auf platz 16 und
gratulierte anschließend dem japaner ryo
kobayashi fair und freundschaftlich zum
gewinn des gesamtweltcups das letzte
skifliegen sicherte sich der norwegische
olympiasieger mario sind wie vor dem
japaner sato und gleich fünf springern
aus dem gastgeberland
eine abwechslungsreiche geschichte
saison 21 22 gegen heute in slowenischen
frühling zu ende
vor 12.000 zuschauern dass hanke schön
ich habe noch die meta aussichten für
sie im norden teils dichte wolken aber
nur vereinzelt regen sonst viel sonne im
bergland aber auch einige quellwolken 9
bis 17 grad im norden bis 22 grad im
süden am dienstag im süden nochmals
freundlich und mild sonst zunehmend
wechselhaft und deutlich kälter viertel
vor zehn ist christian sievers dran im
heute journal ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen guten abend es morgen wenn sie
mögen